hey i'm kane i have a super monotone
voice
it might not come off that way in some
videos because i edit the
out of all the pauses and gaps i never
thought that it could be improved
this month i am going to speak to a
speech therapist
to fix my boring voice in the past i've
lost 40 pounds i've gotten a hair
transplant
and this is the most life-changing video
i've ever made at buzzfeed and you will
see why
one of my biggest insecurities that i
don't talk about i'm very nervous
because what if
i can't change with all that said let's
jump into it
let's go meet our speech therapist my
name is amy i work on
people who want to improve their speech
singing to acting to presenting
it's not about the speed you don't need
to speak fast if you
stop and you think exactly what you want
to say your point can come across much
more pointy i noticed
you use your hands a lot a lot we talk
about what's called the power box
which is right here you always see
politicians doing this you want them
flailing all the way because then your
ideas are flailing
but if you have it right here what you
need to do is really try
this is your exclamation point what
other things do you think i could
improve on potentially
potentially and you left it right there
i didn't know if you were done with your
sentence or not
versus if you would have said so what
other things would you like me to work
on
i would have gotten the clue like now
it's my turn to talk so especially for
an
interviewer another thing let's work on
yeah eye contact
because you keep looking up at my flashy
light and it makes me want to be like
what's up
is something there it's very vulnerable
for both of us
but vulnerability is what makes for good
content good conversation
good dialogue i'm really nervous because
at the very end of the month
i'm giving a speech in front of over 500
university students
i really want to dig deep and apply
everything i'll learn
to give the most inspiring and honest
speech i've ever given
one of the things i did is go out and
talk to
co-workers that i have asked them what
they first thought of me when they first
met me
the first couple times that i met you
yeah i thought you didn't like me
because your voice
before i got to know you i was afraid of
you because i always thought you were
angry
since you're monotone i don't know what
you're feeling like are you mad are you
frustrated
are you happy you're so busy and then so
short the combination of that makes it
sound like
people are bothering you you've known me
the longest we were sitting next to each
other as interns
well i didn't think you liked me very
much when i first met you you were
always very helpful
but you just seemed uninterested did you
ever think i didn't like you
yes 100 i did too
wait wait wait i sensed a lack of
interest i wasn't sure if you liked me
or not because
i thought we were friends from the
beginning friends from the beginning
no i'm realizing a lot of stuff about my
life that i did not know
at what point did you know that that's
just my personality versus like that i
don't like you
probably about like a year yeah a year's
history okay
like nine months like a baby when's the
first time i came to your house oh yeah
yeah were we friends then yeah we were
friends then okay
my life is alive i'm so stressed
yeah i know you know and and so i know
that's not the case i knew you were nice
when you were
sitting at the stages by yourself and i
stopped and i was like i'm just gonna
finally talk to this guy oh
and you're like so nice just like get
that in a fire do i have
we all have inner fire kane why you look
like you got heartburn
to hear that it took ryan nine months
to know that i didn't hate him sucked i
just think about
all the potential friends that i could
have made through the years
i did not expect to get
emotional about it my perception of the
world
is a lot different than how
it actually is like i didn't know so
many people in my life felt
the exact same way holy i don't even
know how to process this i love trying
to fix things
improving myself and growing as a person
every chance i get
working out getting fit smiling more
getting like pre-diabetes in check
getting a hair transplant getting a
personal assistant like all this
stuff and one of the biggest issues that
i've had
only now am i making a video about it
i'm gonna attack this like a
[ __ ] ninja
by the end of this this is not gonna be
how i'm gonna be talking
[Music]
i need to break myself down to build
myself up from the bottom up
when you're excited it's like from here
to here other people even sometimes will
be like is kane okay with that and i'm
like yeah
you thought even if someone says
something to you that's wild or like
uncalled for
you'll just be like that's about as
expressive as you get when you're doing
a comment
or a statement or you want to sound
confident your voice needs to go down
my name is amy i like gum
i like gum i like going the moment or
syllable right before the very end
you're going high low
i like gum i do want to learn to garden
because i think that's a really good
skill
great don't drag out the last words
either you can just take your finger
touch your thigh i started studying
video in college
that's it kate and i will go to dinner
or something and i'll be like oh my god
that was so good
kate will be like it was pretty good
[Music]
you always say stuff is pretty good when
it's excellent
what is it going to take for you to be
blown away by cuisine
[Music]
i really need to wash my car because
it's really
dirty i want you to get that across from
me with just saying
no no no no no no no
[Music]
i really need to wash my car because
it's so
dirty so when i took your words out you
use
every other part of language to get your
point across and the other parts of
language are intonation
or stress
[Music]
how am i with compliments it's still
just very dry
i said your makeup look good today yeah
yeah yeah your makeup looks good
i mean but i'm extra so i want you to be
like come on face
because it hangs me up okay lipstick
that's how you give compliments it is
so i just want you to know here's the
thing
in my mind that's how i'm thinking
seriously yeah oh
i really like how the white cuff folds
up on your
shirt that's so different i've never
seen that i've seen a thousand white
shirts
but that is different and i was
authentic about that i've never seen a
shirt that came like that
thank you but i want to see it and that
was your compliment and you felt it from
me
so you've given me several gifts through
the years i gave you
a polaroid well this is the thing i
think you genuinely did enjoy the gift i
did
freddy's a good gift giver i think what
you said was like oh i've always wanted
one
because i know that that's how you are i
know that you did like it i appreciate
that here you go happy birthday
thank you
um
you're finding the one piece of truth in
whatever it is that you're wanting to
complement
wow you know why this is awesome is i
felt like i had bad breath today and i
could really use this
thanks so much yeah literally every
single session with amy i have a new
revelation it's mind-blowing
week two lots of stuff is being thrown
at me i know you went on vacation
so i would ask oh so like where are you
going asia
really oh cool like are you going with
friends
yeah some college friends really whoa
finding the genuine interest in someone
else that's the thing
that is going to spark more conversation
so tell me about your pink hat i have
five of them that's crazy
but five of the same pink hat the same
exact one
with no logos or anything no that's
already something that i'm interested
about
we're gonna talk about getting what you
want this is one thing that i know i'm
bad at
i feel like i asked for help but i don't
know how to
do that in a sweet and daring way
think about why a waiter is so friendly
because they want a tip when you want
something the complimenting of the
ability that you were trying to get the
help with
i loved your work that you did on
last week's video i would be so
appreciative if you could do it again
for mine
that can be asking their advice you know
so much about this
i don't know anything about this is
there any way you would be willing to
tell me
i really value your opinion you make
very passionate emotional engaging
work i almost wonder like it'd be
interesting if people watched your work
and then met you and like are you who
they imagined
right their head or something as i was
leaving
her next clients recognized me and they
went oh my gosh
you're came from buzzfeed i literally
was like
yeah i am nice to meet you i waved and i
ran you're like oh yeah bye it
just ran off how do you think that comes
up that i don't
like them you say hi and that's not you
no
it takes the same amount of time if you
stop change directions
one introduce yourself two ask their
name
three close it out why am i so
awkward i've already been more emotional
than i have in the past like five years
feeling a lot of feelings i don't know
how to deal
yikes you are probably one of the best
communicators that i've met
if not the best like in the past few
weeks have you noticed
anything different given the amount of
stress
that you're under getting a lot of
really amazing things out you seem very
positive grateful anytime there's been a
problem that you then need to go to a
bunch of people to work around
there's been like a real level of
gratitude and appreciation and lightness
that i have seen
how to talk to somebody who's helping
you out the three things to tell them
number one this is the thing you did do
and i liked it
so it gives them that confidence boost
so they're coming into it with a smile
if i'm talking about your outfit today i
really like your outfit i love
how that pink hat brings out your cheeks
and now the exact thing that i want you
to change
i love to see you in a blue hat let's
see what that does to your ass mm-hmm
because if i just came to you and said
you should try a blue hat
you would think like oh gosh can i not
wear this hat
i'm so bad at building rapport in all
aspects of
my life also i inherently don't think
i'm that interesting
this is where i'm saying you don't have
to lie if you're like i don't find
myself so interested
you can be self-deprecating i don't know
how to do that tell me
five things that just aren't very
awesome about you
i'm horrible at communicating i probably
work
too much i have really oily skin i have
weak knees
i'm like really messy if you're in their
home you've got such a beautiful home
it's so perfect and neat and tidy i'm
like a total slob at home
it makes people feel at ease when they
realize like oh you're not perfect
either what do therapists ask
how do you feel so it's open-ended very
similar to tell me about yourself
tell me what's going on how's all that
thank you i think part of being gay
in the closet throughout my life has
prevented me from
being able to be vulnerable even after
coming out talking about it how does it
make you feel about it i think it makes
me feel like it's
not totally my fault keep going
i wonder if things would have been
different being more open as a person
earlier on okay so we had a nice little
character session here
yes
and it all started from me saying
i'm like in training to be a human right
now
you're like yoda every week i'm like
caring to learn more and it's been
really eye-opening
and life-changing your epiphany today
that's a huge epiphany like what do i do
also know that finding the reason why
is huge you said something so key in
there you said
maybe it's not my fault it's not your
fault
like a it's not a fault but it's not
your fault
and that's a big deal to take off some
of the pressure and stress too
something about crying and opening up
and being vulnerable like they're all
tied to
my speech pattern i did not know
this video was gonna turn into this like
about me
coming out like what the this is crazy
being in the closet for so long i just
kept trying to deflect
attention from myself i finally know
what i need the speech that i'm giving
in two weeks needs to be about
i'm a pretty private person so opening
up like this honestly is really scary
but i know i gotta do it
[Music]
i'm directing a 30 minute scripted video
i have not directed a scripted thing in
two years
i'm hoping that what amy teaches will
help me on set
directors are the fathers of the set you
need to make sure that the whole family
is happy
and all of a sudden it'll be so much
easier to tell them
what you need to tell them i had a table
read yesterday the genuine compliment
openness to hear their input i think has
really
been helpful have you seen any changes
when you compliment like me and shane
like i liked how you guys did that let's
try it again in the middle of it you
said
brian i like the pizza lines those are i
like those and it was simple that was it
these
lines are great okay thank you small
talk before
totally like 180 well you asked like oh
so how's the dating life and then i was
like
wow and then i started talking if i met
you today
i would think that you liked me right
off the bat i think you warmed up
a lot let you like smile more you think
out loud a lot more than you used to
dude i feel like you're going down like
the right path i think a way that you
express affection for people is
demonstrating that you have faith in
their skills or that like you respect
what they can do
like the way that you work with kevin
rdp
it's very clear that you think very
highly of him and you're like partnering
with him
honoring people and respect is a big
part of how you
relate to people i mean i definitely
like that you noticed that the only
reason i'm able to
trust you guys to do it is because for
kevin like all the shots
are two to three times better than i
imagined makes my job a lot easier too
and same with you brian like you care
about the character and the lines and
how it's coming off
you're always like super fun and chill
to work with thank you
i've definitely seen improvement you're
gonna be like a natural conversation
and i'm gonna want to see your speech
and see how you did i just wrapped the
very last
day of my scripted video i love that
they picked up on
me trusting them in their creativity i
felt emotional like hearing that because
that's what i wanted out of this process
the fact that they said yes
to joining me on this journey ultimately
does show that
they do want to work with me now that
that's down
i'm gonna switch my focus to prep for my
speech
holy
i am still writing my script right now
the most important thing is structuring
the speech have something important to
say before you can
sound good saying it so i'll italicize
where
the emotion is gonna be when i talk i do
this like leaning
back and forth thing is there anything i
can do to not do that put the weight on
one foot and barely have your other toe
there
and get a highlighter and just highlight
the parts that are fun
your cadence is up you're not monotone
at all
i'm happy with the speech i am exposing
myself 100
i've mentioned stuff that i have not
even talked to my close friends about
i'm nervous but i think this is what i
have to do like this whole speech and
this whole
experience in this video is about
opening up and
not being afraid to be vulnerable
[Music]
hey boston university i am kane and i
will be on your campus tomorrow at 6 30
pm
along with a few other asian american
guests i will be sharing a lot of
intimate stories that i've never ever
shared before
and there'll be a q a after and me and
green and i'll see you there come hang
out
so i am in my hotel room in boston
the city is so cool i just want to feel
as comfortable as i can with the words
so they have
impact i hope i don't choke what if i
choke i hope
that the students get something out of
it i'll see y'all tomorrow
let's give a warm welcome to kane dip
i want to start off by apologizing to
all the people that i've spoken to in
the past
in auditoriums just like this i wasn't
being honest with them i used to teach
finding your voice
as if once you find it you're done but
the truth is
i'm still finding mine at six years old
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed my parents
and i were invited
to go to my teacher's classroom after
hours
as we sat in that colorful classroom in
the miniature wooden chairs
my teacher told my mom and my dad kane
asked
too many questions they wanted their kid
to
thrive in this foreign school system and
they looked me in the eye
and said white
which translates to ken stop asking
questions
and so as a six-year-old kid i quieted
my voice
and hid away my curiosity baimin is a
chinese
term that means to save face
and it describes the lengths an
individual will go to
in order to preserve their established
position in society
at 19 years old after my freshman year
of college
i got my braces off finally and
i was a dancer and i was feeling sexy af
and i was ready i was ready for my first
kiss
but who do i kiss i was nowhere near out
of the closet
i couldn't even say the word gay out
loud and so
i jumped on craigslist
i actually met the sweetest boy i'd ever
met
eventually he asked me to be his
boyfriend
but remember i had to pay me right and i
told him no
because i didn't think that it would be
possible a week later
i mustered enough courage to ask him to
be my boyfriend
at 19 years old i finally started
raising my voice just a little bit and
started to explore my curiosity
at 23 years old one day i was sitting
with my mom
and she asked me kane when are you gonna
get a girlfriend
and instead of nodding like i normally
would and letting it
go away i told her mom
i'm gay i don't want a girlfriend
i already have a boyfriend
and she didn't take it well the thing
that hurt me the most was she said
kane don't tell your father don't tell
anyone
keep it inside and for the first time in
my life
i saw that my mom was embarrassed by me
instead of saving face i let mine show
and it wasn't a face that she recognized
as her son
a month ago i read a comment and it
wasn't the first time
why is cain so monotone and that
triggered a
deep-seated insecurity that i wasn't
engaging enough when i spoke
and so i did what any other good
buzzfeeder would do
i decided to make a video and it would
be titled
i hired a speech therapist to fix my
boring voice
she had me sit down with a bunch of
people
and ask them what did you first think of
me when we first met
to my utter shock and horror
every single person thought that i
didn't like them
when we first met one of my cokers
thought i didn't like him for nine
months
that's the time it takes for a human to
be formed
my best friend freddy she said that she
also thought i didn't like her for
months
and by that point i thought we were
besties
my old voice was direct it was stern it
made people believe that i wasn't
playful
or that i was too busy to be bothered i
had to face the fact
that people thought i was the grinch who
stole christmas
when i thought i was cindy lou
one particular day in one of my sessions
with amy
i had an epiphany one that would change
everything
going into this month-long experience i
thought that my lack of communication
skills
was because of my cultural background or
that english was my second language
i never considered the fact that being
in the closet
for so long and hiding so much in myself
that i
accidentally hid away part of my
personality
and only now 16 years down the line
am i starting to uncover it i'm sorry
that i used to think
identity and voice were outward
checkboxes it's
every single building block every
encounter that we've had
every bully everyone that's told us to
shut up and sit down
every crush or heartbreak we've ever
felt every misunderstanding
and attempts to fix it every time we
face our fears
and all the times you run away from it
every compliment that we've given and
received
every truth and lie we've ever told and
every time
we apologize please don't let others
quiet your voice
and always remember to embrace your
curiosity and if we need to show our
face
instead of saving it it might be the
only way for us to honestly grow
thank you
[Music]
is
you